Facebook is firing 11
000 employees they lost nearly and
that's just 200 billion dollars in just
one afternoon I don't think that's going
to be happening anytime soon and there
is something happening in the online
digital space that has advertisers
pulling away from Twitter even before
Elon Musk bought it which is another
perspective that people should
understand here
I don't think so centralized social
media should be used for profit anyway
um
me and my little [ __ ] complaints which
is no I want to put video clips on I
want to put this on I want to do that
because
yeah but Rumble I love Rumble but
Rumble has problems what problems I mean
technical problems well they owe me
millions of dollars to start with
because they've put uh ripped copies of
my movie up like every single day even
though I know the CEO I know the
Acquisitions guy I know every single
person over there and they can't get the
YouTube algorithm where you give YouTube
an imprint of your content and there
there can be no uh bootleg versions and
so it's like you know everyone who
claims the money for you or something or
a lot right exactly and so like well
well once well we're on YouTube like
we're on Google Play so it doesn't do
that but um and isn't that funny how
actually the only once we were on
YouTube meaning we were helping YouTube
make money did they do that for us for
the rest of the time we had to do phys
every single link had to be an actual
takedown
um but then and the best part is these
people would put it up and they'd be
like some a-hole named Amanda millius is
trying to take down plot against the
president she's probably a leftist
trying to keep us from the truth and I'm
like have you watched the credits it's
my movie I'm taking it down because it
cost money to make and they're like if
this is so important you should just put
it out for free and you're like right
that's right let's not build an industry
let's just let's make like subpar art
and just put it out for free that'll
that'll really take down Hollywood
that'll work
um our people are so stupid sometimes it
drives me nuts but uh they said the same
thing to Matt Walsh over what as a woman
oh I'm sure I'm sure they did you need
to release it for free and then you're
like why we're trying to we're trying to
make an industry I I I'm completely now
listen I get into it with daily wire
like all the time like I get into it
with Jeremy I get into it with Ben I get
into it we've known each other since
back in La I almost feel like it's to me
I don't take it too personally I'm just
like we're kind of like
you know rolling around like it's fine I
supported Matt Walsh's that movie quite
a bit because that was a very important
movie and I thought it was well you know
that was something I liked that they did
when I don't like something I say it
when I don't like something Dinesh does
I say it when I don't like something
like you know Steven Spielberg does I
say it because I went to film school I
like criticizing movies that's what I do
like it's not a big deal it's only they
take it so personally that they're just
like oh my god
um but yeah even on on stuff like that
like I understand why they have that
subscription model and why you just
described the Twitter subscription model
in such a way I mean it really is one of
these things where once you let in
advertisers you're letting in a sensor
board advertising is a censorship this
is this is why the same thing happened
we started pushing uh timcast.com trying
to build memberships to the website
that's why Infowars was the way is the
is the it only survives the way it does
and then they're even gonna go after him
this is the crazy thing because I get
hit up all the time by big networks
being like we should do a deal and we're
gonna give you yeah but this is fun
because these people they they and these
are Big networks these are Big networks
they seem to think I'm an idiot and
they're like why don't you do a deal
with us and we're going to pay you eight
figures we're gonna pay you all of this
money and I'm like oh yeah okay I know
what you're saying what you're saying is
you want me to read ads five times per
show that's right and then you'll make
eight figures take a cut off the top and
then give me dude we don't do that
because we don't want advertisers to do
contracts with us and then come back and
be like you know that last episode you
did we're not sure you know and then oh
no oh no we're gonna no no no we do a
handful of ads per month we do like six
and I'm like hey if you want to
advertise with us this is the show you
get we had Milo yiannopoulos the other
day you got a problem with it don't run
ads on our show that's how you have to
be but they I know that if I sign one of
these deals with any one of these
networks they would have said something
like you know we don't think you should
have Milo on because the current
advertisers that's exactly how it plays
out yeah
no become a member at timcast.com
I mean you're totally right about that I
mean that's the that's the reason that
like I'm you know you asked me a moment
ago or what's you know have you worked
on a movie since plot against the
president answer is no I'm building a
company the reason I'm building this
company is because I need a place where
the conservative
documentary and you know I'm working on
a couple of scripteds but that's just my
thing
um where the conservative world that's
going to do documentaries that would
normally just would crowdfund them and
just put them out on YouTube or put them
up for free on whatever
um that's their only way of getting
around the censorship is to not make
money but that's not an industry we're
not going to beat Hollywood without
being an industry which is why even when
I tussle with daily wire or I tussle
with Dinesh D'Souza who uses my movie as
a um as a search engine thing for his um
movie that did not as well
um all of that like that's fine that you
know I get it I'm sorry either you know
there's competition I would hate me too
if I was him
um but but uh the the fact is is that
you're not gonna beat anything you're
not gonna be you're not gonna create
this free speech world if you don't have
a competitive industry it is about the
money we need to be able to tell
high-level artist creatives we're gonna
pay you and and we're gonna pay the
investors investing in us we're work
we've got basically
and they're told by their bosses they
have to say woke stuff they can say no
they can come here because I can go work
for anyone but more importantly offer
those people jobs and I don't have to
and I can pay my investors and that's
the great thing is that it's like like
why the and then you're talking to these
investors and a lot of my investors are
Republican donors I'm gonna be that I
can say and you're like Okay cool so
you're gonna let your money on fire four
times you know or every every four years
every two years and
um I get it it's a tax write-off or it's
a this or that or you're just
ideological or whatever it is but I'm
like I'm not asking you to donate I'm
I'm in you're investing in something
where I am one of three companies that
makes something for the entire United
States yeah and tell me about like how
is that not like the greatest deal ever
well more importantly people need to
understand that voting with your dollar
is sometimes more important than just
actually voting where do you put your
attention where you click what you watch
absolutely matters but you also have to
put the money where your mouth is and
again I used to rely on YouTube ads and
they used to limit my ads and then they
fully cut me off from the monetization
first yeah I was I was literally I was
like what the hell's going on here this
doesn't really make sense here I
remember the first ones to get hit with
this let me put this into context for
everybody Luke you've been on YouTube
since like YouTube started 14 15 16
years there didn't used to be
demonetization oh there was you had ads
turned on or ads turned off and I
believe that we are change was the first
channel because they would manually go
in and turn the ads off on your channel
yeah without any notification without
any email I sent out a code back on yeah
yeah I was like what what's going on
here and then no one knew what was going
on no one would get back to me We snuck
into a major YouTube party talk to the
head of monetization I don't know if you
do you remember that one when we stuck
when we stuck in with Casey neistat
right and I was there with the head of
YouTube monetization she's like I'm so
sorry I don't know what's happening here
we're gonna figure this out for you
don't worry Luke we'll get back to you
they never got back they were they were
mad that we were in there yeah we're
like oh how did they get in what do we
do do we kick them out yeah we literally
stuck in there it was hilarious it was
it was awesome it was a lot of fun what
I'm one of my own uh you know well I
mean personal memories but I just wanted
to say after they demonetized me I was
like screw it I'm gonna start a t-shirt
company you can't censor t-shirts in the
real life I started my own members area
you can't do that and it's only because
of user's support that you're able to do
what you're you're you're doing that
you're able to do what you're doing and
I'm able to do it I want to explain to
people how easy it is so uh we went I
can't remember where it was it with
VidCon or something yeah I don't know
yeah no VidCon in uh California and so
we both knew people at YouTube I knew a
lot of people because I'd consulted for
Google and YouTube on live streaming
technology and mobile stuff and so when
we go up to where this party is I'm like
let's see what happens I see someone I
know from from YouTube and they're like
sorry it's like there's already a list
we can't people in and I was like I was
like come on I was like we're here you
know who I am and they were like we just
can't because like there's capacity I
was like okay there's a super exclusive
VIP party with a big list security
guards everywhere no one no one else is
getting in no matter what so so Luke and
I walk around the perimeter basically
just like taking a look at things trying
to because that's what you like figure
out what's going on and then we walk up
to the entrance and then we waited there
and then we saw Casey and istat walking
in with his Entourage and then we just
squeezed as close as possible to Casey
neistat and then he started yelling
about how they were like they stopped
him and they're like your friend can't
come in he's like what are you talking
about this he's a big YouTuber and then
I'm like yeah you know like and Luke is
like what do you what do you mean and
then finally they're like okay Casey
we're so sorry you can bring your people
in he's like all right and then we
walked on in and then and then we didn't
have any wristbands or anything and then
we were like oh we need a wristband we
didn't get one there oh I'm sorry and
then get a wristband is that easy yeah
yeah that's that's if you're meant to be
there you will be there yeah if you're
persistent enough you could get anything
in life but but again like if you just
follow the old model if you follow the
old models and you don't innovate you
don't create your own members area you
don't create merchandise you don't kind
of think of ideas out of the norm you
won't make it in this business because
this business is shutting down the door
to anyone that dares to question any
kind of reality yes and you just have to
stay one step ahead but again you gotta
give the credit to AJ on having done
that back before any of us I mean at
least I don't know about y'all well he
he was doing this before social media
that's what I'm saying and it's like and
I remember that episode to this day will
always be etched in my mind that episode
he did when
um
um Matt uh uh drudge showed up out of
nowhere and and did that episode and he
said start your own websites always have
your own form of income do not let them
put you in their little internet gulags
that's what they're going to try to do
and this was Matt drudge before whatever
happened to Matt drudge where he sold
the site or I don't know I don't know
what happened to Matt drudge but the
point is is like this this was this
episode it was in like 20 I don't know I
was in like film school so it must have
been like it was 2008 I think I was
warning in 2008 that there's going to be
censorship coming on this platform
yeah and it was it was like it was about
but it was about exactly what you guys
were talking about where it was like you
have to stay ahead of the curve innovate
like sell other products
um have have your own website like have
your own member site have your own this
that they can't control do not depend on
YouTube do not depend always on just you
know Twitter social whatever social
media of the day was popular at that
time Instagram you can expect the
establishment to finance its own demise
and they won't ever do it you know a
good example that is I wanted to include
corn in this conversation and ask him
how the industry has changed as far as
monetization station as far as money has
you have you noticed anything in the
industry yeah I mean I mean I was
thinking about that almost the whole
time uh that you guys were talking about
it because there there is a uh a shift
that hasn't happened yet and and I'm not
sure if if they really know how to make
it happen uh because the the box that
you're in in in in the traditional way
of doing distribution
uh that that really comes with a lot of
control mechanisms like you were just
talking about you know there there are
certain parameters that you have to you
kind of have to creative creatively in
terms of yeah you know and that but but
then where where are you going to take
your your film your original content and
Market it to get the same type of
monetization potential as you would get
in home every single platform so you
take it that's the thing you just it's
just how you do the deals this is what I
that's the that is the one thing I broke
on plot against the president that is
the reason Amazon will not take
documentaries anymore but you yeah
documentaries are a different Beast is
it different beasts than than scripted
content and stuff like that especially
when you're dealing with the the all the
genre specific issues and stuff like
that but but really it's about
platforming at the end of the day there
there isn't right now currently uh that
that I have found a really strong
distribution platform with direct
monetization for the for the films where
you're actually getting a percentage of
yeah every person right away per view as
it goes yeah every person is a grifter
well there are a lot of grifters and
every single person that has I have met
with that I have sat with that was like
we have a platform and it's going to be
for all the people that are you know
dissident culture and it's going to be
about not censorship and it's this and
it's that it's some guy who literally is
taking somebody's money and running I
have not I have one Avenue that I think
has done this properly and it's rockfin
rockfin has a very good back end that's
trustworthy and is actually I believe
what they're telling me I've as somebody
who has a film that is the number one
documentary to this day on Amazon on all
the different weird platforms right
because I want to try all of them
because I was like I got it because
eventually they're gonna come for me
they're not gonna let me put something
out I gotta know what's the next big
platform you're completely right and
I've been saying this for three years
I've been saying this at every time I
speak at uh at at certain organizations
that invite me to come speak regarding
platforms I say this every single time
you build me the platform I will give
you the content I make content I don't
make plans so corn where do you see this
going well I mean what I do see that's
working interestingly enough with with
uh run hide fight with daily wire and
all that is that I think that there's a
there's an opportunity for a people who
already have built out platforms to use
those platforms themselves as a
distribution in outlet for for scripted
and you know but then like five people
see it no no that's not true you're
talking about people who have millions
of people millions of followers on their
platform and the reach that that can go
to from there I think that that's one
option because otherwise it goes back to
a corporate you know a corporate style
eventually anyway uh when you have you
know platforms that are that are
controlled by corporate interest thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time